like Harry said tree instead of three
trees cuz I'm hurtin very Irish I like
it very ingrained in the Irishness be it
be around you it just makes me feel like
I'm back home you don't like my hair is
accented like how everyone who's doing
an Irish accent just turns into a
leprechaun it drifts a little bit
naturally towards that disposition hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to the forest with Jack say
hi hi we build stuff we built this city
you made that joke already didn't you
yes I've seen on my jokes man sorry I
mean there's popping and then there's
this okay it's just the next level of
YouTube if you want to go farther you
gotta not just copy you got a steel
everything before they do it or I gotta
go deeper we couldn't no oh wait I
thought I was I'm fired in my empire
okay we we built this thing we really
couldn't afford a bigger one we built it
well actually we could have without much
time we were just talking another but we
also build a gazebo yeah so like we
built those two in the space of time it
would have taken us to build the other
log cabins oh no you don't know why that
log cabin is enough because we are a
married couple man and wife and we're
happy on this island near the plane like
not morons yeah we changed it up his
mother we need to where's the benches we
need to build a bench we can build a
tree bridge a3 plus my twin treehouses
hold on a freaking minute hold on yeah
we can build tree Birds why wait wait a
minute yeah we can do that yeah that's
always good I didn't expect you to like
actually wait why wouldn't I I'm a
polite guy I wait my turn when it comes
to these things whatever they may be for
my lovely wife I would wait I guess hey
hey what I okay I am very pretty so am I
am I am I the husband or am I the like
we should have like a man off see who's
been here oh not back by tomorrow jack
off as well and then a mark off and then
we'll really fulfil the circle of all
these in happen we will have a jack off
you did not think that one through for
all you people out there have your own
jackoff and Mark off competition at home
and tell us to why is your win will it
relax you more will you have all those
fight minions the claim is making a joke
here your jig turning it into a
popularity contest is not what the you
are not even close to being sitting on
the bench have a seat have a seat
I'm Christmas I'm not on this bench
either I'm inside you follow God Hey
sitting on my night hi hi uh well I'm
gonna turn off the camera let's get some
sensual music up in here hot stuff
Naz I was really gonna add music in
there thanks for ruining the moment
well copyright you can every just say go
to black okay and we're done that was
beautiful yeah I know
I'm axing cry Maxine there's nothing
wrong with a good krygasm no wait when
did this turn into r-rated before it
yeah I'm trying to like tested limits of
where pg-13 stops uh well I make us beat
pg-13 change from when we were like 13
well I guess you can say one f-word in
pg-13 you can say yeah one f-word and
then you can have like box we were 13
you couldn't even say [ __ ] yes so does
like things drifted right wait first I'd
like ass or [ __ ] on TV late at night
usually everyone's mind was like oh my
god yes you can't say that at least in
American look at the heavens nature
didn't rip open God Himself was just
like shaking his finger through the chin
yeah he was saying he wasn't even angry
just disappointed he was a cloud just
like oh that's a worse
oh no God no heaven for you hey that's a
bad that's a bad HBO yeah anyway so
we're what were we talking about
I have no word this is like you're drunk
minecraft it just goes no words it's how
every my video does it goes nowhere
that's that's my chin who's good our
prior problem was that we build all this
stuff in the mean time so we didn't
waste your time that wait conversation
off camera that you guys yeah you don't
want to know about that that was just
that was
not a lot of money handling how he's
gonna pay me for being the funniest
person in this year exactly I I have to
steal his jokes in advance so he has to
give them to me
and yeah we have a list of what jokes we
can steal so I'm gonna be like everybody
do the dinosaur that's gonna be in the
next year he's mean his and then I'm
gonna have oh yeah you're gonna be a
great back and forth and I'm gonna have
another stereotypical thing that just
takes to complete piss out of him yes
since he's just going overboard with his
what have you got
what have you got come on German and
Korean duo everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm a big goofy goober
huh Baba's not really insulting me at
all sexy just don't know much to Who I
am
that was pretty spot-on I was I was
confused as to who I was when you were
doing did you hear that laugh track I
added even no but I'll add one now you
don't need a good I'm gonna add it God
you do not know anything about editing
flowers so professional okay so anyway
let's do something besides yeah we have
no we had natives on our butts
no we don't actually where is he doing
good we killed the natives they were the
scouts we killed them all they didn't
tell anyone we were here we need to find
a cave that's why we were doing we're
gonna find a cave yeah so a cave is
normally where that boat is on a beach
okay I'll leave me to the beaches right
you're right
follow me honey like I like here you
were just gone pointing I said follow me
well I don't need to wait for you wait
what is this these trees I didn't knock
him down maybe I did I don't know
was this really weird square rock you
like halfway through there's a canoe or
a kayak I'm not falling down there I do
not trust this yeah I'm not going down
there either I'm going down the nice
safe path cuz over there over there do
you know that song I've watched too many
of your [ __ ] videos that's what's the
problem okay cuz what that is it's a
song from the 1930s or 20s was the world
war one or two I can't remember whoa did
you get hurt yeah my screen is black and
white what do we do oh I got lots of
pills yeah so anyway that's from like oh
that one of the world wars
a song that was like played on the radio
over here just like get people like
thinking about the troops over there or
are thinning in like a musical thing it
was yeah it was musical like a Broadway
thing no no is there water here that I
can't see again yeah like right at the
edge don't fall in those it's very deep
yeah I see that I can see the bottom you
just seem like a big precipice yes it's
a precipice and then there's water like
in the distance put aside here what
right did I do good precipice yes it's
so that you could easily guess precipice
there's rope I feel like there's a cave
somewhere around here this feels like
kie right my cave senses are tingling is
I built i but I built a bow okay how'd
you build the bow I got some sticks oh
dude you're mocking me there is that
what you were doing yeah oh god I'm
underneath the rocks now you're under
the water what are you doing we don't
know where I am I can't bring you
anywhere wait where are you oh I'm up
I'm back here and I can't follow you
because you went under the water there's
a cave somewhere here we gotta find it
we owe it to the viewers out there yeah
yeah viewers hey do we owe you that yeah
they trust in us right everybody I find
boy what is this fire into YouTube you
know turn him back now he's just
swimming I I went the other way I was
coming to you you didn't need to go jump
into the water so sure hey hey see it's
like your outline like your shadow it's
like the ambient occlusion there's a
lizard underwater killed it I got it I
guess rabbits underwater yeah yeah
because I'm here and I'm awesome so I
made all this happen and I seen the [ __ ]
good lord seeing this [ __ ] I see four
lizards well yeah because I think they
are spawning down here because I'm here
and it's yeah I don't know your server
I'm in charge I think the game has
spoken that I
deserve to be the leader of this
expedition okay well if Italy sigfig
good footage let's put the vote to the
fine people watching right now who's the
leader mere Joe don't do that hash tag
team Jack whoa
team Jack I'd vote for Team Jack anyway
I would like I wouldn't follow me
anywhere I was just on my World of
Warcraft guild did you know how to start
that up oh yeah it's all like Ross beat
you yesterday he put that in a bad light
like he just like kill I got killed
because what I did was I was called into
battle and they were right outside our
garrison and the way phasing works is I
can't see them until I was already in
the middle of them so I was running ah
all of a sudden there were all these
game grump people everywhere and he ran
right into him and the course they
killed me of course like of course I
died it was gonna happen but and then
Ross is like jerking off to himself like
oh we're so great we killed mark
he was just by himself and alone but
yeah yeah it's just like yep feel pretty
good about that do say thing is I
actually call up all my guild mates we
get in the big raid we're out there and
we're about to go charge and fight him
and they leave they kill me Oh bollocks
bang leave and then rustling oh we're
the greatest every week check it out
everybody have a good day we did good
Panem dissolve on the backs come back
Ross exactly like if this episode is
gonna come out like a week later after
war has already out yeah who else but
let the story be known that's what
really happened
it happened yesterday the fourth of
December yes fourth of December always
remember as a fourth of December yeah
from oh man I'm leaving you far behind
RNA yeah cuz you're hurting spring off
I'm doing a swimmer mommy teeny tiny
legs I'm not even sweating I'm trying to
find where there would be a cave or
something I think I think I can get back
them to land over here yeah actually my
guild on that server it's almost full
and we've getting tons and tons of
high-level characters is crazy
do you see the charity you know I don't
I've never played it but I mean I tried
like the
I was like and not really for me it was
kind of afraid at the same times like
maybe I like it and never ever leave
yeah that's what happened I mean I
started playing back when he first came
out I've never really stopped like I've
paid every month since it opened for a
subscription even when I was a G that's
like a crack addiction God it's I just
think about how much money that's been
over the years is like oh yeah so if you
can people are talking that up at home
that's all in the conference right now
whack spent four million dollars in
world of warcraft
whoa how many people are spending four
million dollars on World of Warcraft
I'd imagine there's plenty well if there
was a way to spend that much money on it
I guess it's like you know I just heard
put I put clash of clans on my phone cuz
everyone's been saying about this not
really gave no god no the game is not
that fun like no it's horrible yeah I
put it on my phone and like I was I was
traveling back from Cincinnati when I
did it and I did a bad I pulled the Ross
I bought the hundred dollars worth of
gems just cuz I was so right I did it I
did it I was so mad at myself after I
did it but I did it because I was just
like I can't do anything I need I got
this game I want to play it so I I
bought the gems and you're the person
South Park was making fun of reason to
person I didn't see the episode you're
everything that's wrong with gaming
right now hey listen hang your head in
shame ah I don't might have an
abnormally large game budget so you know
it's cuz you have too much YouTube money
that's your problem
god I wish but no cigars playing on my
polish managin and a dime left it in
your road by the fire playing clash
offense yeah I can play
oh good great incredible even Nami you
you played like you played like Dragon
Age recently right yes I've been playing
that I mean to play more sorry just put
me fait Han right yeah III put like 10
hours into it like the first two days
yeah I was like oh my god I'm so
addicted cuz I played it first yeah I
was like I couldn't really get into it
that's cuz I picked like a warrior and
didn't really like it yeah and then it
hurts you saying it was amazing and I
was like maybe I should give it another
shot and then I just got addicted yeah I
played you it's it's an amazing game
just for the story like I love the world
like having a world is important
heylook land I think I'm on land right
yeah but yeah I've been able to play it
in like a week Meeny sucks oh no time I
need to get back into it well actually
hey that was a lot of talk yeah we did
that well talking's good like that's
like we were talking off-camera about
one of the reasons why I like the game
grumps is because it's like a podcast
yes they have games playing at the same
time this is my don't listen to people
talk I guess we're not hyper edited
entertainment machines all the time yeah
kind of sometimes yes sometimes either
way what was I saying I was in the
middle it's trying to make a point but I
forgot what I was talking about between
the paying millions of dollars for World
War one the goddamn world
hahaha geez just there was a lizard here
like I put on my armor go okay good for
you anyway re for definite you in
between the world of warcraft and the
other thing o class clans that's right I
bought a hundred dollars worth of gems
and I kicked myself in the face because
I spent all the gems and I was still
nowhere I spent a lot of dollars to go
nowhere like you yeah I got it me it was
really well designed to incentivize me
to pay on like buy gems cuz those games
you're like they're perfect addiction
machines
I hate in-app transactions and I did it
I did it anyway I said I'd never do it I
did it I pulled a Ross and I did it wait
wait wait wait wait go back there what
the Ross to Ross did that on an episode
of steam train he like with planes Hello
Kitty Island Adventure something oh he
bought $100 worth of fake money is like
it wasn't it wasn't the amazing
world wasn't it was the amazing world
yeah so yeah I played that game you have
to get your parents to like wait your
email did you made it I didn't I don't
like seananners those guys they made
video is haunted I was like can't upload
this oh my gosh aim OH
I uploaded a dark version of Hello Kitty
Island Adventure there really is a game
hello kitty oh yeah I saw that you shall
you're like fate your face was like
frozen in the corner yeah just because
creepy is possibly it works it was
pretty creepy I guess good Oh
settlements yay let's say hi in the next
episode cuz we're out of time
so yeah hey how about that we spent old
ages talking hash and shooting the shiz
so plain enough stupid mark was not
stupid I just made a stupid decision
that's it Alex no wars thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos 11 check out Jack's
channel in the description below he's
got funny videos and as always we'll see
you this seems like a bad idea
you're pretty I smell bad I also have to
go in the bathroom don't mind the owner